RACHEL: BUSLOADS OF MIGRANTS
CONTINUE TO ARRIVING NEW YORK
CITY MAYOR ERIC ADAMS IS
OPENING A TENT CITY REPORTEDLY
BEGGING THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FOR $500 MILLION.
THE MAYOR RIPPING REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS SAYING NOW MORE THAN
EVER IT IS CLEAR WE ARE AGAIN
DEALING WITH A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS CREATED BY HUMAN HANDS
WHILE OTHER LEADERS ADVOCATED
THEIR MORAL DUTY TO SUPPORT
ARRIVING ASYLUM-SEEKERS, NEW
YORK CITY REFUSES TO DO SO.
HERE IS NEW YORK CITY
COUNCILMAN JOE MARELLI.
I UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION OF
PEOPLE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD, THE
THINGS THEY HAD TO SAY, I
WOULDN'T WANT THIS TENT CITY IN
MY NEIGHBORHOOD PARK.
THE BORDER STATES, FOR MORE
THAN THEIR SHARE.
OF THE BURDEN.
SHOULDN'T THIS BE SHARED?
>> IT IS UNFAIR TO BLAME THE
BORDER STATES SAYING THEY
DIDN'T SHOULDER THE BURDEN,
WHEN FOR YEARS WHETHER IT WAS
PEOPLE SEEKING ASYLUM OR PEOPLE
COMING ILLEGALLY THEY
SHOULDERED THE BRUNT OF THIS
PROBLEM AND IF ANYTHING
UNDERSCORES THAT IT IS A
PROBLEM WE ARE NOW SETTING UP
TENT CITIES ON BEACHES IN NEW
YORK CITY, SOMETHING WE DO WHEN
THERE'S A HURRICANE OR FLOOD OR
EARTHQUAKE, WE ARE RESPONDING
AS THOUGH IT IS A NATURAL
DISASTER, LOOKING AT A CRUISE
SHIP TO HOUSE THESE FOLKS.
THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM.
RACHEL: LOOKING AT CRUISE SHIPS
AS A SOLUTION.
>> WE HAVE NO IDEA WHEN THIS
WILL STOP OR HOW MANY WILL
COME.
THE REAL STORY IS HOW THIS WAS
NOT AN ISSUE, AND THEY BROUGHT
THESE FOLKS TO CITIES LIKE NEW
YORK AND LIBERAL ENCLAVES WHERE
EVERYONE HAS A COEXIST BUMPER
STICKER ON THEIR SUBARU AND IT
BECAME A REAL CRISIS.
>> THIS DISTRICT IS AOC'S
DISTRICT AND THIS DISTRICT
VOTED DISPROPORTIONATELY FOR
DEMOCRATS FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
POLICIES, POETIC JUSTICE?
>> IT IS POETIC JUSTICE AND SHE
SHARES THE BLAME, NOT THE
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS FAULT, AND
LED BY PRESIDENT BIDEN, WHEN
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS STOP
SEEING PEOPLE GO ACROSS THE
BORDER THAT IS WHEN THEY WILL
STOP SPENDING MIGRANTS NORTH,
WE WILL NOT SEE A STOP SO AS A
NEW YORKER I WANT ERIC ADAMS TO
GET FEDERAL MONEY, DON'T WANT
TO PAY FOR IT MYSELF BUT HE
SHOULD BE OUT THERE WITH OTHER
BIG-CITY MAYORS CALLING ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO STOP THE
FLOW OF THIS MIGRATION CRISIS.
RACHEL: IT IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY CRISIS.
HERE'S A QUOTE FROM A VETERAN
WHO LIVES IN THAT AREA WHO TOLD
THE DAILY MAIL THEY ARE NOT
MIGRANTS, THEY ARE ILLEGAL
ALIENS, 800 YEARS AGO PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT THE LEGAL WAY
THEY CAME HERE TO ELLIS ISLAND
RUN BY THE ARMY MEDICAL CORPS,
YOU CAME TO AMERICA YOU HAD TO
HAVE THE PAPERS, YOUR SPONSORS,
YOU COULDN'T JUST WALK IN HERE.
HE'S DOING WHAT HE IS TOLD BY
WASHINGTON, IT IS BEING
DICTATED AND WE DON'T KNOW WHO
IS RUNNING THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> HER FAMILY PROBABLY CAME
FROM THE CARIBBEAN AND YOU CAME
HERE LEGALLY AND YOU DON'T WANT
TO SEE THESE TENT CITIES, HOPE
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TAKES
PAUSE FROM THIS, DO SOME
REFLECTION AND REALIZE THE
BORDER IS WHERE THE PROBLEM
STARTS.
RACHEL: THE DISTRICT IS VERY
BLUE.
WILL AOC FEEL THE POLITICAL
HEAT FOR THIS DISTRICT?
>> I DOUBT IT.